how pain was handled prior to anesthesia
the patient would be given a shot or two
of whiskey and literally a stick to bite
on while they operated and it was a
brutal time and you can imagine what
patients facing operations were fearful
of
hey gq i'm dr leonard lee welcome back
for part two where i'll be breaking down
more surgery scenes this is the
breakdown
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
first up awake
i want you to take this inject the heart
and put it in the body that's something
you would never see in the operating
room her hair would be covered and she
would be wearing a mask the purpose of
hair covers is to prevent hair and
dander from your head falling into any
surgical field or surgical wound
all right
so this is a heart transplant and
they've removed the patient's heart and
that machine that they're showing now is
the heart lung machine and that is
what's supporting
the heart functions which is pumping the
blood maintaining a blood pressure
maintaining
oxygen in the blood to feed your vital
organs so that they can be sustained
during the time that the transplant is
going on heart transplant is actually
one of the most successful transplanted
organs in the entire body the most
common transplants are kidney
transplants but the heart transplants
have the best survival rates in terms of
patients and also
the least amount of rejection
don't worry we taped our eyes shut to
prevent corneal abrasions some
people sleep with our eyes open and we
do that to prevent injury to the actual
eye itself
all right i need some suction no no no
no no no please god no
okay oh no please
there are multiple parts to anesthesia
the general parts about anesthesia are
one to maintain a level of sedation so
that the patients remain comfortable in
terms of pain and sensation to pain the
other part is to keep their brains quiet
so that they're not aware and
occasionally
one
part of that anesthetic management may
fall a little short there are reports of
patients having awareness during
operations where they hear conversations
uh they're aware what's going on around
them during the course of surgery there
are a lot of things that the
anesthesiologists have at their disposal
to try to prevent these things from
happening different monitoring devices
of brain waves etc that can help prevent
these things from happening
next up 127 hours
so this is absolutely brutal to watch
and to think that someone could actually
cut their own arm off is almost seems as
if it would be unrealistic but we all
know that this is actually a true story
so the purpose of that band that he put
around his arm it's called a tourniquet
and the purpose of the tourniquet is to
cut off the blood supply to his arm so
that when he cuts through those major
blood vessels that feed his hand he
doesn't bleed to death so it's actually
a very very smart thing to do
so he's probably touching a nerve there
and that's probably what's causing more
intense pain than he was already feeling
from the cut and the break
it is true though that intense pain can
cause you to pass out it can cause you
to hallucinate you can get disoriented
pain is an incredible thing how pain was
handled prior to anesthesia the patient
would be given a shot or two of whiskey
and literally a stick to bite on while
they operated and it was a brutal time
and you can imagine what patients facing
operations were fearful of
next up grey's anatomy
all systems ready
the davinci sihd surgical system that is
an actual surgical robot that is the
company da vinci and the s was one of
the first generations of the robot they
came out for use in surgery
all systems ready that is what it looks
like it does not talk to you however
they made it sound like something out of
star wars where the robot is actually
conversing with you
feels pretty good doesn't it
so you can see that she was sitting at a
console and that is how it works the
actual robot is
in the patient and docked to the
operating room table the surgeon sits
away from the actual robotic arms and
sits at a console and in the console she
puts her head into it and it provides
for a three-dimensional view so you have
depth of field and it provides six times
magnification the hands are put in these
casters that
translate very large motions of the
hands into very fine motions at the
fingertips of the actual instruments
that are within the patient the
advantage of the robot is that it
removes tremor
all of us have a certain degree of
tremor in our hands the longer the
instrument the more tremor you see at
the tip of the instrument it takes that
tremor away this particular company is
the leader is the industry leader for
robotics and when any
program or hospital or university
hospital academic medical center is
talking about robotic surgery they are
talking about using the da vinci next up
er don't pull so hard with the babcock
you'll tear the gastric artery i'm not
pulling the hell you're not dr
morgenstern you're obscuring my field
oh son of a [ __ ] you tore the left
gastric i wasn't anywhere near it
suction
so in the operating room it's really
rare for things like arguments to occur
it it just wouldn't happen there is
conversation there is direction
there is
correction things like that do happen
but it's much more calm it's much more
collegial the primary surgeon always
stands on the right hand side because
peter benton was on the right hand side
of the patient that means that he is the
primary operator for that operation
give me more suction i can't see what
i'm coagulating all right we have to
open no no no no no we can control the
bleeding so coagulating is a way to
control bleeding it uses electrical
current to actually burn uh small blood
vessels and and stop them from bleeding
i'm starting internal massage still in
v-tip so that's the endotracheal tube
that's the tube that is connected to the
ventilator and it goes into the
patient's main windpipe and that can
provide oxygen to the patient during the
course of the operation when the
patients are under general anesthesia
they can't breathe for themselves and so
the machine does the breathing for them
i can't find the bleeder
all right we've got to crack them
damn it i said rip's better let's move
so during any type of an elective
general surgical case it'd be really
unlikely to require opening the chest to
get control of bleeding the purposes of
opening the chest is to put a clamp
across the aorta the aorta is the big
blood vessel off the top of the heart
that feeds blood to the entire body and
by clamping off the aorta you allow the
heart to fill with blood and so that the
heart can do its job of pumping the
blood at least to the brain and to the
lungs while you try to get control below
the diaphragm in the belly it'd be very
very unusual doing that during any sort
of general surgical procedure next up
scrubs so you want to talk to me about
your appendectomy 15 of all surgical
complications are anesthesia related so
i would like to use hypnosis instead of
the traditional anesthesia with today's
science and anesthesia the likelihood of
anesthetic complications is far less
than 15
patients these days because of the
internet and media come in fairly
educated about their disease processes
what operation they can get what
operation they might get but it's rare
for a patient to actually dictate to you
what they want and in what direction
they want to go
my appendectomy patient wants me to use
hypnosis instead of anesthesia hypnosis
is a very powerful tool it's helped
people with depression and weight loss
that help me quit smoking hypnosis is
for birthday parties and bad vegas
lounges it is true that hypnosis is very
very powerful tool and it can help with
all those things that she just talked
about but it'd be very very unlikely to
be used in surgery appendectomies are
fairly common operations the appendix uh
is in the
lower right side of the abdomen and it's
a what we refer to as a vestigial organ
meaning it has no role there was some
role in immune response and things like
that many many years ago centuries and
centuries ago but today
it doesn't have a purpose but it can get
clogged up and it can get infected and
that's what leads to what we refer to as
appendicitis or inflammation of the
appendix and that is one of the reasons
why the appendix would be removed
all right that's it thanks for watching
these clips with me i hope you learned
something until next time